[Musique]
ces danseuses et ses danseurs qui
s'échauffe font partie d'une des
références mondiales de la danse
contemporaine
le béjart ballet lausanne la compagnie
créée en 1987 par maurice béjart est une
habituée de l'opéra royal de versailles
j'ai la chance de pouvoir venir à
versailles régulièrement graf directeur
qui nous invite et qui est toujours
intéressé de voir mes créations donc je
me fais plaisir
c'est une chance de pouvoir c'est dans
un espace pareil dans un théâtre qui est
aussi beau qui est aussi habité donc
c'est chaque fois un plaisir pour les
danseurs pour pour tout le monde de
passer ici depuis la disparition du
chorégraphe fondateur de la compagnie en
2007 c'est gil roman qui continue de
faire vivre le répertoire du béjart
ballet lausanne et répertoire qui
s'enrichit avec de nouvelles créations
tous les hommes presque toujours
s'imagine a été présenté en avril 2019
en suisse les représentations
versaillais ce sont les premières en
france
c'est très difficile d'expliquer le sort
d'un ballet dont il n'y a pas d'histoire
a priori pourtant il ya des histoires
possibles l'intéressé c'est que le
public puisse faire le voyage lui-même
et son propre voyage c'est des histoires
de voyages de traversée de d'aller voir
de l'autre côté ce ballet le résultat de
la fascination du directeur artistique
pour le musicien contemporain américain
john zorn sur scène une vingtaine de
danseuses et danseurs deux ans de
travail et de réflexion ont été
nécessaires pour aboutir à cette
précision des pas les créatures mur et
parfois longtemps l'avancé puis parfois
je fais une création assez rapide sur le
moment qui n'a peut-être pas le même
poids mais tout aussi l'idée d'être sans
arrêt en mouvement prochaines
représentations pour la compagnie
athènes lausanne ou encore hong kong et
tokyo en 2020
[Musique]